[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d'un talent il
interdire pour ou contre le béton cela
semble un peu caricatural comme débat
est joué d'avancé le béton est ce que
l'on appelle les bétonneuses où les
bétonneurs ayant depuis longtemps très
mauvaise presse
mais il se trouve que le béton n'a pas
que des ennemis là aussi ses
thuriféraires et parmi eux à célèbre
architecte qui lui mais qui lui a même
consacré une pièce de théâtre le béton
en garde à vue alors là il y a matière à
débat entre deux pointures en plus d'un
côté rudy ricciotti l'ambassadeur du
béton de l'autre philippe madec l'un des
pionniers de la construction écologique
en france qui lui préfère le bois ou la
terre coulé alors rudy ricciotti je vous
présente vous êtes fils de maçon grand
prix national d'architecturé en 2006
vous êtes un amoureux du béton il y en a
dans tous vos projets le mucem à
marseille le stade jean bouin à paris
le bordeaux métropole arena vous est
également l'auteur de l' architecture
est un sport de combat de l'exil de la
beauté vous réédité chez textuel le
béton en garde à vue une comédie en
trois actes
inspiré de vos déboires judiciaires qui
est aussi un véritable plaidoyer en
faveur du béton que vous estimez attaqué
de toutes parts et pour de mauvaises
raisons alors pourquoi ce sont de
mauvaises raisons
en deux mots pourquoi sans de mauvaises
vraiment parce que d'abord c'est nier
l'histoire de l'architecturé
contemporaine
car même avec un patrimoine qui va
doivent mieux se perd et à le corbusier
avec de nombreux chefs-d'oeuvre ceni
aussi une tradition et un récit
constructif qui a plus de 2000 ans
depuis depuis la rome antique
rappelez-vous le panthéon a rendu c'est
du béton
c'est du béton extrêmement savons mais
je pense qu'au delà je crois il faut
bien réfléchir à se poser la question
qu'est ce que c'est que la durée de vie
un ouvrage ça doit sa durée de vie et
son empreinte environnementale est aussi
calculé sur sa durée de vie et pas sur
une situation est le maire mais ça on va
développer dans le débat très bien
philippe madec vous êtes architecte et
urbaniste vous êtes l'un des pionniers
de la construction écologique en france
au béton je les dis vous préférez le
bois ou la terre coulé on vous doit
notamment le pôle oenotouristique de
saint christol l'office public de
l'habitat aquilani ça à bordeaux les
quoi l'éco quartier du pont des
tanneries à dijon vous avez reçu le
global award for sustainable
architecture c'est un peu le nobel de
l'architecturé durable
c'est l'un des trois initiateurs du
manifeste pour une frugalité heureuse et
créatives en 2018 qui a été signée par
plus de sept mille professionnels à
travers le monde et vous donner jusqu'au
15 décembre un cycle de conférences en
ligne sur le thème métamorphosé l'acte
de construire c'est tous les mardis de
19h à 21h pour vous vous l'aviez dit
dans le monde il faut se désintoxiquer
de la technique et de la monoculture du
béton pourquoi en fait je pense qu'il
faut savoir
irrité une magnifique histoire de
l'architecturé quand on hérite et une
part que l'on garde mais il ya une part
que l'on rejette
je suis un grand héritier d'aimé des
modernes comme comme redire à l'évidence
il ya une part des moyens que je ne peux
pas du tout accepter s'ils saluent
projet génériques et c'est celle qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui le monde des
bâtisseurs est responsable depuis de 40%
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il est
absolument nécessaire de changer notre
posture face à la fabrication de
l'établissement humain et si je dois le
dire en une phrase je pense que si le
19e siècle a été révolutionnée en ce qui
concerne le bâtiment par l'acier si le
20e siècle
effectivement révolutionné l'écriture
grâce au béton 21e siècle sera grâce aux
matériaux biosourcés alors voyez la
sûreté dans votre dans le béton en garde
à vue vous dit que le procès de la
filière bio béton est un bon exemple des
dommages causés par une réglementation
devenue assassinat force d'étendre son
champ de préjugés la filière béton est
véritablement attaqué mise en procès
aujourd'hui écouter s'il n'y avait que
la filière béton qui a attaqué qui a
attaqué
on essaie fondé la consommation de sable
consommation de ciment est critiquable
mais je développerai tout à l'heure des
nouvelles tendances et je découvre que
madec aussi s'intéresse à la terre
couler mais moi j'ai inscrit ce métier
le nôtre dans une responsabilité
citoyenne plus large qui sait aussi de
dire des choses on peut pas de la même
manière les c'est mentir
de la même manière qu'on ne peut pas
laisser passer ce qui dysfonctionne dans
notre démocratie
je suis peut-être hors sujet mais moi je
peux pas me taire sur sur des attentats
récents
ça me concerne comme français comme
citoyen je pense à la barbarie islamiste
et à l'islamisme politique qui sont des
sujets qui me concerne comme architecte
et comme citoyen et je vois pas pourquoi
je ne dirais pas ma solidarité les
enseignants aujourd'hui à l'intérieur de
l'espace républicain et laïc et je pense
que madec est d'accord avec moi n'est ce
pas philippe et vous phare évidence mais
pour ma part je souhaite rester dans les
enjeux qui sont les nôtres
est ce que comme citoyen je suis sûr que
toi et moi partageons absolument des
délais les mêmes fondements mais comme
professionnel il ya des présents jeux
qu'il faut que nous débattions entre les
voir c'est vous même peut-être pas un
débat c'est juste une explication une
mise en lumière de la situation dans
laquelle roman on est vous remettre
ensemble je dois te dire que je pense
qu'il ya ya une erreur sur le nouveau
béton
en fait c'est pas le béton qui est en
procès
tu penses nulle part personne nommé le
butoir possède par contre le ciment et
le ciment portland et le béton armé tel
qu'il a été fait au xxème siècle à base
de métaux portland en utilisant le sable
et en me disant beaucoup d'eau et
d'acier oui
ciment ce béton armé l'a émis en procès
mais le mes tours d'immeubles enfin je
devais ou à quand je fais du pisé je
fais du béton quand le fait du béton de
change a fait du béton fatwa il ya mille
manières de faire du béton qui il a
historiquement et est du coup le mot il
faut pas il faut pas qu'il faut pas s'y
attaquer de cette façon là il faut
comprendre où est le souci est le souci
très clairement c'est sur le ciment le
ciment qui sait est très émetteur de gaz
à effet de serre le sable bon c'est ce
que ces lots on risque d'en manquer un
jour ça suffirait à a condamné le béton
vous êtes d'accord
rudy ricciotti mais écoutez je vous dis
que je fais des bâtiments en béton de
chanvre ce qui inquiète les enseignants
ahuri qui ont peur que les étudiants de
râteaux le chant soul un pétard il faut
donner des explications jeu j'ai des
projets en béton de de terre et de la
même manière que je fais aussi bâtiment
en béton bas carbone
belfort - avec des résidus industriels
la tendance allait là n'est plus
effectivement dans le béton béton des
années 60
ça fait un moment qu'on va tourner la
tâche on n'a pas fait le point avec
philippe madec ça fait deux morts avancé
par rencontrer mais philippe devine est
les précautions qui sont des siennes
je suis engagé sur d'autres aspects de
recherche alors la trêve très
pragmatiquement en ce moment en train
beaucoup avec des déchets industriels
tire les poubelles de l'industrie la
fumée de silice le leti des hauts
fourneaux la terre surtout la terre des
déchets du grand paris bien falloir
qu'on en fasse quelque chose
les terres de gars gagnent qui sont des
terres qui servent pour faire des
colorants naturels
il ya déjà plein de sous produits de les
déchets industriels notamment ceux de la
métallurgie qui sont
qui sont exploités et la tendance la
tendance je viens d'avoir une
conversation avec mon fils qui
cherchèrent ingénieur des ponts et
chaussées mathématicien et médine a
tendance aujourd'hui si de rechercher
l'intérêt de vie et des volumes pérenne
parce que le bois ne remplira pas les
conditions thermiques acoustiques ou
mécanique c'est pas à l'échelle je
travaille avec du bois aussi évidemment
mais c'est pas à l'échelle des attentats
à faire du bois coupe-feu et puis à
d'autres difficultés le bois on le sait
aussi je le peux être pervers mais les
actes de monoculture de pin douglas la
cow parade ce qu'on appelle ou un plan
du paquebot koulou l'assaut au cordeau
sur des hectares qui dramatique pour
l'écosystème
il va bien falloir bilan p c'est un coup
c'est de couper rase cette monoculture
du pin douglas présente le gros doute de
gros doutes quand même entre les membres
qu'en sera-t-il apte à la construction
ou à la rénovation ils n'ont pas toutes
les fonctions mais mais moi je crois que
la réalité la réalité elle est toujours
entre autres des deux voilà la tendance
ça veut dire ce qu'il calme fascinant ce
qu'on a une école d'ingénierie en france
de très haut niveau
il a tendance est de travailler sur les
particules pour ne plus créer la
porosité ce qui affaiblit la durée de
vie des matériaux c'est la porosité
comment les matériaux s'agglomèrent à
échelle macroscopique afin de pouvoir
utiliser autre chose que du ciment et du
sable il s'agit là de particules fera
t-elle
c'est comme ça que ça va se passer c'est
à dire que prendre un exemple par
exemple c'est l'idée de volumes énormes
de périmètre gigantesque avec pas de
volume prend l'exemple du flocon de
neige qui a cette capacité à s'assembler
et avoir d'énormes d'informer le futur
il est là et le futur il va se faire
aussi dans nos écoles d'ingénieurs je
cherche le nom d'un grand
français quitte à la retraite qui était
patron de normale sup qui a bien évolué
et fait évoluer les bétons fibrés à
ultra hautes performances qui dit la
produire un texte récemment y raconte
qu'elle avait mauvais temps c'est dans
la physique des particules de la
mécanique la chimie de la
cristallographique d'un est mathématique
etc dans la transversalité disciplinés
que ça va se passer
le futur il est là il est dans votre
futur seul le sable et ce n'est plus
aussi bon mais c'est déjà un futur bien
engagé un fait paddec oui comment vire
il est indispensable de coco nous
fassions tous ensemble deuil de cet
héritage des modèles
il faut arrêter des monocultures du
béton il faut arrêter les produits
génériques
le béton fer à base de ciment portland
est un matériau aujourd'hui génériques
vous l'avez partout dans le monde c'est
un matériau petit ce qui n'a pas
d'intérêt pour les cultures qui n'a pas
un intérêt pour les savoir faire et qui
s'installe comme il veut où il veut
comme il veut faire ce deuil là et est
en fait j'entends les joies que mercredi
en train de le faire c'est indispensable
c'est indispensable parce que ça nous
permet de faire changer la structure
il y avait faire profondément changé la
sécu pour retrouver des savoir faire et
des savoir faire plus qu logo et il faut
pas juste s'en tenir aux matelles ouais
je sais bien et je ne veux pas détourner
l'objet de notre discussion jour et une
image puisque c'est le mettons qu'il a
raison pour laquelle nous sommes
ensemble mais c'est toute l'histoire de
l'art chic et moderne qui est important
de remettre en question quand vous
faites un bâtiment qui est un bâtiment
en structure béton avec quatre façades
pareil et qui est climatisé vous
détruisez la culture ou détruisez le
rapport au contexte et ça c'est d'eux
dont ceux dont on doit se passer
donc c'est pas juste de la matière si
aussi la technique qui nous qu'il est
indispensable aujourd'hui 2
de re questionner en ce qui concerne la
matière il est vrai qu'elle ait des
recherches aujourd'hui absolument
passionnante jeu
je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est le
plus en tout cas ce qui m'enthousiasme
le plus c'est ce sont toutes les
recherches qui s'opère autour du autour
de la terre et de la terre coulé et je
préfère cette solution là en otage
j'utilise aussi du béton de chanvre
voilà ce différend clair j'utilise aussi
d'autres villes de béton l'énigme mais
l'inter couler m'intéresse parce qu'en
fait la terre couler elle se coule à
l'endroit où l'on recourt prend la terre
elle se fait de façon écologique
il n'y a pas de processus chimiques pour
transformer la matière ce qui n'est pas
le cas avec les déchets la méthodologie
c'est un produit qui n'est pas
industriel et c'est important que nous
sommes prêts
du coup il est hors des logiques à la
fois de l'économie de marché et et de
l'industrie cette capacité que l'on peut
avoir de regarder autrement la mise en
oeuvre de la matière avec les savoir
faire locaux
moi je trouve ça un enthousiasmant je
veux revenir je pense que nous prenons
un plaisir incroyable a fait
réapparaître cette puissance des savoir
faire locaux et des matières issues des
nuls quoi inquiéter
ce n'est pas je souris un peu parce que
ma tête c'est très bien combien j'ai
attaqué le mouvement moderne depuis
longtemps ça fait 40 ans que je fais ce
métier et s'est fait 40 ans que je fais
des critiques du mouvement de pensée
moderne comme destructeur des identités
territoriales et des ressources
territoriales jeu juste de rappeler que
le béton mal aimée est le seul matériau
non spéculatif au monde puisque chacun
des deux pays dans le monde produisent
en béton autant dire autant du bois dont
on découvrira car même qui a des
filières spéculative aider à son
manipulateur et notamment sur des
interdits des formations je veux pas
faire monter le ton du débat mais tout
de même fini tu peux pas faire des
dégâts n'a sens
leurs coups de feu avec du bois tu peux
pas faire des planches et quart de la
masse acoustique avec du bois tu peux
pas faire il ya des départs mécanique de
l' ouvrage dont tu sais très bien qu
elle ne peut pas être en bois
ce n'est pas possible et moi le sujet
qui m'a qui m'intrigue dans le bois
c'est la notion de distance tu parlais
de distante le béton il est toujours
produits dans un rayon de 30 kilomètres
par rapport à l'endroit où on ne
m'utilise tous les cas c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça dans de nombreux pays et
je moi je m'interroge sur les distances
parcourues par le bois pour venir
d'autriche
je m'interroge sur l'étuvage sur les
routes température par danone de
nombreux heurts ont donné une stabilité
mécanique au beau jeu même courage je
m'interroge aussi sur la colle utilisée
en le ccar mais le tout n'est pas clean
pas s'interroger aussi sur les lobbys
qui sont faits au niveau législatif pour
démanteler la filière de car même un
million d'emplois autour des industries
du béton et convenant tout de même que
le béton est devenue une définition
générique mais qu'il faut arrêter de lui
faire le procès de ce qui fut dans les
années 60 comme si on nous faisait
encore le procès du colonialisme tu vois
c'est good avant ça suffit parce que la
recherche développement
la recherche développement
elle est très très lourdement engagée et
ce n'est pas porter à connaissance du
grand public dont il faut pas faire non
plus de dire de démagogie quand tu me
dis on coule la terre in situ mais aimer
la france n'est pas l'afrique tu sais
très bien que tu peux pas utiliser ça
comme ça c'est pas la terre du
terrassement
bien que l'intérêt de la terre et c'est
pour ça que je m'intéresse de très près
que je commence à avancer des projets ce
sujet l'intéressé que la terre la plus
médiocre et utile pour faire du béton in
situ mais je crois qu'il faut être clair
sur les enjeux
ils ont un jeu ce n'est pas la
destruction des autres pour exister
davantage c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche tout à philippe et c'est bien ce
que je pensais de vers c'est très
intéressant parce que la question des
coûts contre le veto est en train de
devenir ou contre le voir parce que la
réalité elle est un peu derrière quelque
chose qui est en train de se passer
c'est pour ou contre la terre contre le
pot
parce que quoi qu'ils enfin tut tut tut
tut près je pense que toi et moi on sait
que l'on est en train de travailler
ensemble sur d'autres béton que ceux du
vatican il n'y a pas d'autre solution
thuiller déjà j'y suis j'y suis même
certain moment mais oui mais ce jeu est
ce que je te critique sur sa faim je
pense en fait aujourd'hui il faut
accepter qu'il n'y a pas que la
monoculture du béton y compris dans ces
bétons traditionnels et celle des temps
nouveaux et qu'il y à une autre manière
de faire qui sont des biens une manière
de faire est dans ton neutre où les
savoir faire y compris avec des manières
contemporain de regarder l'autre
par exemple je suis très intéressé par
la bri par la terre trop pressés qui est
une nation contemporaine de de mise en
oeuvre de de la terre et la btc comme on
me permet de faire des stocks absolument
magnifique
je suis très intéressé par le béton
coulé parce que je ne veux pas faire
avant le savoir-faire et grandes
entreprises de béton qui savent utiliser
la branche de new façon unique qu'est ce
qu'on va acculer dans la banque
ça c'est l'enjeu d'aujourd'hui est ce
qu'on va couler en avance a pu être du
béton et du sien en portant les les
entreprises les compagnies qui
fabriquent du ciment réfléchissent aussi
déjà déjà sur ça donc voilà on avance on
sait qu'on avance sur le waik il faut
pas être à ce point proposé au moins de
terminer sur ça parce que tu as quand
même beaucoup attaqué le bois et mais je
pense que tu n'as pas fait tout à fait à
raison la france sera la troisième forêt
européenne après la suède et la finlande
la france a la capacité de produits
le bois de construction sur son
territoire
la france a des industries côté des
industriels locaux qui fabrique celtes
et ducrocq stabilité timmer et pas
uniquement coller mais cloué et donc la
france possède à la fois les artisans
qui savent faire ça depuis toujours
parler qu'on avait oubliées et les
industriels qui savent le faire je pense
attendu en bretagne ça le bas mais ça se
baladant dans les landes matt matisse en
alsace on a cette solution est là pour
te répondre sur ce succès il est
impossible de construire angoissant
métaux qui est ce que tu sais que tu les
entends dire on ne peut pas faire de
cage d'ascenseur ni de cages d'escaliers
sans béton mon oeil quoi mon mieux et
elle est têtue construits en bois et
pour régler la question du feu tu me
dira ma selle et c'est pas compliqué
dans ces îles et moi je trouve
passionnant de chercher des solutions
nouvelles et je trouve qu'on est dans
une époque un prêt et oise et créative
est suivi en grande partie par les gens
entre 24 et 35 ans et cette génération
là elle a envie de faire autrement
et elle sait qu'elle a les moyens de le
faire mais il faut pas désespérer quoi
il est possible de faire avec beaucoup
plus de matériaux qu'un autre génération
que génial
j'écoute j'entends ce que tu me dis mais
faut pas laisser croire que la france
sera dorénavant construite en bois avec
du pain de glace des résineux au travers
de deux coupes rases dramatique pour
l'écosystème
je ne faut pas non plus caricaturer moi
je bois je n'utilise que j'utilise mais
pas de manière structurelle parce que
j'ai pas confiance et que je fais un
pont autoroutier à marseille je ne vois
pas
dire à mon client l'état que ce pont
sous lequel passent des camions je vais
le faire en bois tu vois c'est pas
possible je doit garantir et la
durabilité dans le temps c'est à dire
sans dans la stabilité de nos ouvrages
sous lequel passe de l'eau puisqu'il ya
une rivière qui passe de sous je ne faut
pas si tu veux droit j'entends mais on
ne peut pas dire aussi n'importe quoi
comme s'il y avait un matériau miracle
avec le bois les connais t il
on est confronté aussi à une pulsion
mystificatrice quand tu me dis la
jeunesse elle est fascinée par le bois
je pense que la jeunesse doit d'abord
être fasciné par le travail le goût du
travail
tu vois moi ce que j'aime de la
minéralité c'est le coefficient bender
métro géant pour objet de d'exiger un
coefficient main d'oeuvre
maxime a un coefficient mais notre
action c'est à dire de l'in situ et la
chaîne courte de production je pense que
là dessus on peut se rejoindre la scène
courte de production a pour objet de
réduire l'empreinte environnementale
c'est pas important sur des centaines
voire des milliers de kilomètres des
profits ou des prestations qui n de
turquie d'inde de chine je ne sais d'où
qu'on va régler la question de cet
aspect chaîne cours de liaison c'est
majeur si l'on veut réduire l'empreinte
environnementale et assez curieusement
l'empreinte environnementale est
inversement proportionnelle au degré
demandeur s'essayait il ya des
conditions sociales de l'usaj qu'on a de
la meilleure le préfabriqué le prêt à
l'emploi
ce n'est pas possible - ce que je
n'accepte pas c'est le travail avec du
contreplaqué
je trouve que ce dernier axe de
l'impérialisme américain
on nous faut nous envoie le modèle
mentale de la maison en kit
c'est pas possible ça c'est pas possible
on a une obligation de durabilité et
j'ai même pas envie de dire de
recyclabilité mais de transformation de
transformation et les question qu'on
doit se poser aussi sur les ouvrages que
l'on construit c'est leur donnerait de
transformable unités j'ai fait une
émission
2t et à quelques temps il ya pas
longtemps vous montrez l'explosion des
hlm
je sais plus dans quel jean de france
comme si c'était un acte héroïque et
j'ai dit mais c'est lamentable
au lieu de détruire en droit réadapter
transformer recyclé même si l'amour
aussi qu'il n'est pas très adapté
c'était largement de la pensée se
battent constructif sur récit
constructif l'on trouvera la réponse sur
la question du coefficient de main
d'oeuvre est ce que tu sais qu'un mètre
carré de versailles a une empreinte
environnementale mètres carrés de
logement social tu sais pourquoi parce
que versailles s'était pas d'électricité
pas de gasoil
pas de transport tout été fait de
manière manuelle
la solution elle est là aussi tu vois le
coefficient de ces deux d'opale rudy
ricciotti c'est le fait qu'on emploie
beaucoup de main d'oeuvre que ce soit
bien clair plus on emploie de la main
d'oeuvre plus vous êtes content il reste
juste une minute avant la pause philippe
madec
on emploie moins de main d'oeuvre avec
le bois par exemple
ah ben c'est tout c'est tout l'inversé
mais c'est pas quelques mois celle de la
pierre et le bois la terre il ya peu de
temps j'ai demandé à une entreprise de
btp très connu pour sa capacité à couler
du béton
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle ne mettait pas
en face à l'ô lieu de faire un voile
embêtant une maçonnerie de terre cuite
la réponse est à mais on n'a plus les
compagnons pour ça au sein d'entreprises
prennent ensemble il ya de la qualité de
la main d'oeuvre au sein de ces
entreprises qui ont choisi le béton et
qui tire au futur ont aussi fait leur
travail
à l'époque où ils l'ont fait mais
aujourd'hui quand on va chercher la
richesse locale quitte à la fois là la
richesse physique de la matière et la
richesse humaine celle de savoir faire
qui est toujours lié la matière physique
on en trouve beaucoup plus de monde on
fait une pause et on se retrouve juste
après on continue ce débat
[Musique]
on reprend notre débat sur le béton avec
nos deux architectes rudy ricciotti qui
publie chez textuel le béton en garde à
vue et philippe madec l'un des
initiateurs du manifeste pour une
frugalité heureuse et créative qui
donnent tous les mardis des conférences
en ligne sur le thème métamorphosé
l'acte de construire philippe madec vous
dites qu'on a on n'a pas moderniser le
monde on l'a bétonnée oui je vois les
élus alors je me suis juste avant de
vous répondre
sachez que nous ne sommes pas
aujourd'hui à sept mille signataires
mais à plus de 2500 signaté la wii tous
les jours finalement le monde des
bâtisseurs se retrouvent autour d'une
idée que pour ma part j'ai résumé dans
moins c'est mieux c'est une au titre de
mon prochain livre qui va paraître chez
thériault mène chez terres urbaines à la
rentrée voyez il y a en fait un
mouvement de fond qui est en train de
s'opérer autour de cette idée que l'on
peut faire mieux en disant moins de
ressources et d'ailleurs at on un autre
une autre possibilité de faire ses jeux
j'ai eu je suis membre du chapitre au
rock du club de rome et le club de rome
à dans les années 90 à un de ces
rapports qui s'appelle facteur 4 et le
sous titre facteur 4 c'était deux fois
plus de bien-être en consommant deux
fois moins de ressources
notre travail est là nous là les
architectes
notre travail est exactement la ferme en
sorte que l'on vive mieux en utilisant
moins de ressources pour moins de
laisser la wii cette ce cycle de
conférences de métamorphoser l'acte de
le construire bien choisi l'actuel
construit à l'acte de bâtir ce que
l'acte de bâtir ses lâchetés pure et là
que de construire c'est ce qui nous
rassemble tous les groupes
ce cycle répond avec des choses très
utile par exemple me disais à raison on
va pas ne boit pas planter toujours la
même espèce pour la coupe et on est bien
on est tous d'accord sur ça
romain fait en sorte que la richesse de
nos forêts françaises d'un seul coup se
perdre dans une uniformité des essences
qui sera coupé et donc il faut que tu
revenir aux gamins si tu attends relie
la magnifique conférence d'emmanuel ps
qui expliquent comment ils vont couper
de façon naturelle les bois qu'ils
choisissent dans les forêts
aujourd'hui tout est en train de changer
et c'est passionnant et c'est d'essayer
voilà je trouve que je pense qu'on vit
là une époque qui n'a rien à voir la fin
du xxème siècle qui est une époque
d'inventions et d'innovations et tant
mieux
j'ai vraiment entendu indien une chute
et vous êtes moins enthousiastes sur
l'époque vous blanc je suis dans une une
désillusion positive je crois qu'il
faudrait side
l'idée de prélever un arbre par ci par
là j'entends le rêve romantique de
philippe mais tout de même c'est moins
d'un bourg sont peut-être des besoins
que ce que la france a aujourd'hui est
faux je veux bien faire attention à ce
que l'on dit parce que il ya une chaîne
de métiers et les savoir faire qui sont
aujourd'hui en france autour de la halle
de bâtir qui augmentent car même pas
qu'un million d'emplois d'ailleurs
plusieurs sondes et des savoirs des
mémoires dans le bénéfice social est
très important je crois on peut pas
indépendamment de toute conscience
politique de toute conscience sociale
imagine le dire mais on va faire tabula
rasa de tous les autres métiers
la céramique l'acier les mettons alors
quand ça fait un moment qu'on raconte
qu'on fait des bétons différents fois
moins d'émissions de carbone extérieure
moi j'ai encouragé le film a des cas
être très prudent parce qu'un jour il y
aura en retour un retour de un retour de
flamme politique
sur ce sujet il n'y a pas de solution
miracle
il ya une entreprise de transformation
cette entreprise de transformation
elle est en cours pour moi ce sont les
mathématiciens et physiciens les
spécialistes je leur dis de la chimie
l'historiographie de la mécanique la
mécanique un sens de la mécanique des
efforts qui qu'ils soient en train de
prouver la réponse à trois autres sont
en cours mais d'imaginer que cette
filière à bois va nous sauver l'âme jeu
je suis désolé je ne crois pas je ne
crois pas et c'est même irresponsable
d'essayer de faire basculer l'économie
brutalement dans une monoculture
industrielle dans la symbolique serait
celle d alignement sur des milliers
d'hectares de pins douglas do philippe a
bien compris aussi qu'elle était
critiquable
n'est ce pas par contre je crois que la
filière d'avenir
ce sera d'être des tons de terre
effectivement qui pardonnez-moi si
j'insiste sur le mot béton le métro le
mot béton ce n'est pas le diable
ce n'est pas la pornographie non plus
car même en ce départ faut quand même
rester un peu raisonnable et je crois
que la tendance mais les méthodes de
terre moi je connais un artisan que je
soutient d'ailleurs c'est toute ma
carrière professionnelle qui
s'organisait autour du soutien aux
artisans aux savoir-faire au travail
manuel
là la vérité environnementale est là
avec la terre à la plus ordinaire celle
qui n'est même pas recyclables pour
l'agriculture c'est bleu plutôt ramassés
au tractopelle là au titre du
terrassement ne sais même pas quoi faire
lorsqu'on fait des remblais ils sont
même un propre représentation
c'est comme ça c'est à dire la
réutilisation
j'ai presque envie de dire prime
utilisation plutôt pour recyclage en
évitant d'être automation voyez pas ce
que même la filière de béton concassé où
on récupère du béton en aucun cas sont
faits des granulats même c'était finir
l'art est en train d'abandonner pour
venir à des bétons avec des déchets
alors ça plaît pas à madec je parle de
déchets
stream il faut bien en faire quelque
chose de ces déchets de la sidérurgie
il faut les utiliser comme des déchets
de terre le grand paris il va y avoir
des gigantesques volume de terre thomas
pas savoir faire va bien falloir
utiliser se taire et à 9 pas la déplacer
on papa la coulée in situ comme si nous
étions dans le maghreb ou 19e siècle tu
vois philippe 7 du 6 au 7 avenue cissé
il faut l'arménie d'une conscience
politique d'une conscience politique et
l'économique
ça existe cette réalité tu vois c'est
tout après du point de vue après je
dresse parler mais du point de vue
architecture wade première expérience
qu'on va sortir un fils en bois c'est
pas marrant quand même tu vois c'est pas
très sexy ça a un côté du rhin je
l'espère protestants lestrem ça rigole
pas y'a pas de récit c'est plat c'est
toujours dans l'ordre du minimalisme tu
vois un côté un peu à ces chants qui est
un peu épuisant c'est pas avec ce
déficit de vertu onirik adossé à une
prétention de vertus environnementales
comment faire émerger de nouvelles
alternatives environnementale
voilà là je dépasse le débat à notre
niveau maintenant c'est celle ci n'aura
que deux espaces c'est il faut pas une
posture historique aujourd'hui c'est pas
juste faire un bâtiment plus ça n'a pas
de sens c'est aussi pour ça que ce
mouvement d'un premier teaser et
créative a de l'importance
das justement elle dépasse 50 chacun des
objets bâti pour arriver à une posture
et c'est ce que je voudrais je suis ravi
de t'entendre parler du béton de terre
je ne pensais pas que tu veux dire est
de cette façon là
10 je redis pour moi il ya la terre il
ya le bois et à toutes les fibres et
avec ça il ya qu une grande chose à
faire tu à dire l utilisation je vais
rebondir sur ton mot réutilisation en
fait tu sais ça chaque année on ne
construit que 1% de l'équivalent du bâti
existant en off on ne fait que 1 % de
plus que ce qui existe donc il ya 99 ans
en compte chaque année on ajoute que 1%
quelle est la part en ce 1 % qui est éco
responsable caudal et donc c'est pas
avec le neuf qu'on va régler
l'empreinte écologique désastreuse du
monde du bâtiment donc réutiliser ça
commence par réparer nous métamorphosé
réhabiliter le monde déjà là encore
construit et relie faut-il encore
construire il faut se poser ça il faut
se poser cette question chaque fois
chaque fois qu'un projet nous arrive il
faut se noierait faut-il ne pas
construire
il y la réponse n est pas gagné elle
n'est pas forcément au construire donc
aujourd'hui la question du bois tu
comprends c'est un complément au monde
qui est déjà là il ya tellement de
millions de mètres carrés de bureaux
vides en ile de france
donc continuons à construire des 10 des
centaines de milliers chaque année
quelque chose qui va pas donc on est
nous dans une situation historique on
est dehors de la conscience de l'acte de
bâtir et donc effectivement nous à la
famille était osé créatif on dit faut-il
encore pensé mais ce que l'on dit c'est
qu'il faut surtout réhabiliter le mans
déjà mais il augmente déjà là on va pas
leur avis avec le ciment portland du
siècle passé ovale réalité avec tous les
matériaux magnifique magique qui existe
je suis en train de faire la médiathèque
du 19e arrondissement à la première
maison des réfugiés de la ville de paris
on réhabilite le lycée jean carré qui
est un magnifique bâtiment
industrialisés en béton m superbe
ton qu'on peut conférer un son d'une
espèce de douceur goût incroyable et
nous ce que l'on rajoute c'est
uniquement du bois et de la terre coulée
est une terre collègues qui est là pour
le coup innovante sans ciment sans sang
chaud simplement grâce à la terre du
grand paris les choses se font tu vois
ce que tu évoquais ça se fait c'est pas
le demande c'est une maintenance et on
va pas attendre
oui on est quand même privilégié tous
les deux il faut aussi se mettre à la
place des autres confrères qui ne sont
pas convoqués dans lé recyclage ou dans
la réutilisation comme nous le faisons
parce qu'évidemment qui s'est
aujourd'hui je suis sollicité sans cesse
pour reconvertir des ouvrages en béton
et je le fais en évitant les
destructions tu vois les immenses
qualités de réparateurs et j'aurai deux
opérations c'est ce que c'est le métier
leur devenir
c'est ça notre question mais moi je n'ai
pas attendu la grand'messe psycho
environnementalistes pour prendre mes
responsabilités
déjà le béton j'utilise avec grâce tu
vois et pas forcément comme une brute
épaisse et je crois que mes oeuvres doit
être convaincre mais j'ai fait un moment
que je marque beaucoup sur la revue
utilisation des ouvrages en métaux une
fois garage une fois un ancien édifice
tertiaire mais je voudrais revenir sur
quelque chose que tu as dit tout à
l'heure quand tu demandais une
entreprise pourquoi elle n'était pas de
la pierre de la terre est une entreprise
très bon à ce qu'on a pu la main'
d'heure alors ce que tu dis est vrai
mais la réponse de l'entreprise est
fausse
la tendance aujourd'hui des ingénieurs
qui gère les entreprises c'est d'avoir
le moins d'ouvriers le moins de celle
chantier lemoine chez l'équipe de moins
de coffreur le moins de boiseur le moins
de ferrailleurs le moins de moins en
moins d'ouvriers qualifiés et je te dis
pas pour la taille de pierre dont on
sait très bien que lapierre aussi qui
doit peut-être te paraître suspecte a
été la pierre à cannes à massada plein
de vie
tu et c est la tendance chez ses cadres
dans les entreprises c'est d'éviter
d'être emmerder par des sachant qu'ils
peuvent être très vite 7/10 qu'alizé
très vite s'ils sont absents mettre en
péril la chaîne de production
on a formé des cadres dans les écoles
d'ingénieurs qui dès qu'ils ont fait 5
ans d'études à dire ça vaut rien seront
pas vraiment un grand prix du point de
vue du savoir qu'ils sont des gens qui
décident censure des bilans financiers
dans lequel ne part ahmed a justement
c'est de baisser la main d'oeuvre c'est
car elle est incroyable c'est un état
sociétale de décadence tu as moi je vois
les choses
on venait peut-être comme l'argent mais
pas ceux de même analyse et sept l'idée
de détruire l'emploi détruire la mémoire
du travail est un acte criminel
c'est pour ça que je t'encourage à être
prudents dans les accusations que tu
portes sur les autres filières de
l'industrie
moi je fais attention à ne pas détruire
des métiers les emplois mais je fais
attention et à défendre ce qu'ils
sachent ce qu'ils savent cependant les
fautes défendre les sachants encore une
fois c'est un mémoire du travail a une
valeur sociale politique et économique
et avant de la déshabiller il faut
réfléchir à deux fois
de sorte que notre conscience
environnementale qui tombe bien commun
l'environnement la connaissance d'un
bien commun nous appartient tous on vit
avec
mais la doxa environnementalistes qui en
découlent comment ça risque de devenir
de demain par un discours accusateur par
le bleu le doigt comme le jugement
dernier
probablement un tremplin du fascisme
car même vous soumettre deux minutes à
la place des quelques millions d'emplois
qui se sentent menacés et savoir écouter
tu comprends ça ce n'est pas un jeu ce
n'est pas un flipper l'économie de la
construction du récit constructif
on ne peut pas uniquement avec une
grande messe reconvertir
r convertir aussi facilement un monde
voilà philippe madec
mais tu penses vers le lit que je peux
pas accepter que tu me traite de
fasciste
je ne traite pas de fascistes j'ai dit
que le discours à venir dans mentalist
va devenir un tremplin du fascisme mais
c'est la relation de trop c'est là où tu
te trompe mais bon écoute 16 ce propos
là je vais te le laisse et je ne pas les
y rebondir ce n'est ni ma vie ni mes
engagements ni ceux du manifeste
[Musique]
on a une vision assez anarchiste de
l'être au monde les gens responsables et
indépendants qui font au plus proche de
leur lieu quelque chose qui renvoie un
mieux-être demain que réponds pas qui ne
répondent pas maintenant parce que je ne
me sens pas je ne sais pas car ni sur
cette idée que l'on pourrait n'être que
de façade atlantique n'est pas un pathos
à ce point là je te dis que le discours
environnementaliste lorsqu'ils
deviennent d'une doxa totalitaire va
créer des rebonds et des pulsions
extrêmement inquiétant dans le monde du
travail
voilà c'est tout je traite pas de
fascistes six projets un petit concert
sujet des palaces on ne peut pas aborder
ces questions de reconversion des
métiers des traditions des phénomènes
dans l'acte de bâtir on doit l'aborder
sans un spectre politique économique
plus large
tu dois comprendre ça voilà mais ça on
le fait en permanence et tout à l'heure
utilisé que toi et moi on avait la
chance d'être appelé sur des bouts sujet
effectivement on peut répartir ces
d'accès qui sont appelés à neutre est le
sujet qui est en toi que quand on a
lancé le manifeste d'un premier teaser
récréative où on a été débordé par des
signatures qui venaient de partout on a
réalisé que le que le monde de
l'écoresponsabilité existé et qui était
constituée de gens qu'on ne connaissait
pas qui était partout qui se bat elle
est seule
et finalement ce que le manifeste à
manifester c'est l'existence de seconde
de l'éco responsabilité de jean qui
avait simplement besoin de se retrouver
entre il a réuni du mouvement c'est pas
dominique nos amis
avant on avait les mois même qui la
faisons vivre la réalité du mouvement
c'est qu'il ya plus de 30 groupes locaux
et nationaux qui comprennent étrangers
qui font simplement un partage certains
nous on tune fin tu sais bien demande
notamment de la compétition celui dont
on a hérité c'est les concours le
rapport au maître d'oeuvre pour mettre
nos vaches c'est ça c'est fini pour nous
on est dans le partage permanent quelles
sont les bonnes ressources
quelles sont les bonnes ressources
physiques quelles sont les bonnes
ressources humaines ou est ce que tu as
fait ça comment tu as fait ça explique
moi on a changé ou notre histoire est
une manière de pratiquer je suis
moi-même ébloui de ce qui nous arrive
comme voilà comme la fois beauté de ses
ambitions individuelles mais tout
partager partager sur on va faire mieux
quoi avec moi j'ai l'impression
pour avoir lu le béton en garde à vue
rudy ricciotti que vous insistez
beaucoup sur le caractère savant sur le
beau travail complexe que nécessite le
béton et qui j'ai l'impression pour vous
se marie mal avec l'idée de frugalité
non non la vous manipulez frais il faut
manipuler le beau travail c'est un
moment qu'on n'entend plus le beau
travail le travail bien résister ce
qu'on entend plus qu'il n'existe plus la
culture de l'entreprise
moi c'est quelque chose qui me motive
voyez et d'imaginer que ce beau travail
n'est pas frugal c'est ainsi stendhal
eux car même parce que le beau travail
s'est passé du temps c'est s'appliquer
c'est être concentré sur ce que l'on
fait et c'est sûr que ça ne ça ne vient
pas tout seul
or le temps que nous vivons aujourd'hui
c'est du temps qui ne laisse pas de du
temps à l'exécution des ouvrages à leur
conception
ce qui permettrait d'ailleurs davantage
d'intégrer les enjeux environnementaux
et là je suis pas d'accord avec philippe
madec qui laisse croire aux curistes
solution miracle parce que effectivement
le boire dix modèles de 16 c du titre
tu vois on est plus de la charpente du
maître constructeur du dix neuvième
siècle je suis totalement admiratif
les charpentes en bois les ouates ge
comme ça ce convoi montagne les
épaisseurs les masses aujourd'hui on est
dans le bricolage
quand vous propose des alternatives à
boisset du contreplaqué cdu s'est
détruit j'ai l'impression d'être encore
plus colonisé par les américains car je
vois ça c'est pas c'est pas mon truc
c'est pas mon truc moi de faire du kit
tu vois ça va on a vécu tous les
impérialismes possible des états unis
toustou c'est le dernier maintenant le
dernier invasif c'est la construction
nous quitte
moi ça me sidère j'ai mal au coeur pour
l'épauler pour les travailleurs pour
ceux qui ont des métiers pour ceux qui
consacrent leur vie à ça tu vois
philippe tu as quand même y être
sensibles à la villa monnaies ça va
convertir sur la terre tu vois bien on
va converger sur la terre et sur la
terre j'en connais un bon si ce sujet ça
je peux dire c'est un gros sujet et
c'est vraiment porteur d'avenir
donc après le chambre j'ai fait du
chambre mais ça reste quand même
anecdotique on vous savez qu'on va faire
du béton aussi demain avec des causes de
ris parce qu'on sait pas quoi faire des
causes de riz et que la causerie c'est
une bulle odeurs donc ça une valeur
thermique en même temps il y avait de la
terre ordinaire jouant de la der de la
terre que tu ramasses là juste à côté de
la route même pas d'un terrain agricole
des terres polluées
tu peux arriver à fabriquer des bétons
avec 20 mégas pascal la compression on a
des espoirs mais il faut il qu'il faut
cesser de laisser croire que le bois ce
qui repousse est la solution à tout ce
n'est pas vrai la solution à tous et le
travail
la vertu du travail de la mémoire des
métiers et le fait que les sachants
soient protégés c'est comme ça comme une
crédibilité politique et paddec oui
enfin ce jeu je pense que c'est toujours
mis en avant
le bois la terre la paille les fibres
les matériaux biosourcés sûr c est que
je ne fais pas du bois le seul
la seule solution de demain je ne
réponds pas et ce serait totalement
couillon de faire je ne réponds pas à
une monoculture par une horde son
monologue culture il ya rien de pire que
de faire ça ce que je voudrais
simplement dire à rudi fait l'expérience
d'un travail à une bourse banquier fait
l'expérience du travail de l'assemblage
parce qu'en fait le bois c'est fédérer
semble du contreplaqué et fâché c'est
pas ça l'histoire de la construction en
bois le le bois c'est des matins c'est
du bois brut local le matin il a jonglé
d'assemblage magique
on vous a pas entendu rire chanter oui
je disais je suis pas totalement puceau
cette question quand même j'ai une école
dans la drogue
toute la toiture la couverture la
charpente est en bois et il ya deux
ouvrages plaint de devoir j'avais du
poids de l'ouvragé la masse je veux à
durabilité mais mais ce que je vois
apparaître dans ces écoquartiers comme
qualifie de succès environnemental qui
sont pour moi probablement désastre à
venir parce que s'ils sortent de la
décennale miraculeusement sans procès
c'est déjà beaucoup
ce que je peux te dire c'est quand même
le bricolage adossés à des chaînes de
fournisseurs qui exclut les savoir-faire
territorialisée des hackers qui
saisissent l'acte de bâtir je n'exprime
pas très bien ça je suis très bien ce
que tu veux dire tu sauf que derrière il
ya une espèce de manipulation
une manipulation nous emmener à
consommer toujours les mêmes produits
plats tu vois toujours et et je sais pas
si je n'y aura pas du rap à un petit
scandale derrière sur les manipulations
industriel autour de la fourniture de
produits plats turin mais évidemment on
parle pas de terres en parle pas de
charpente au massive
on parle d'autre chose voilà parce que
tu sais bien que le niveau tire vers le
bas
c'est un niveau de savoir-faire et de
récits constructive qui tire vers le bas
qui tire pas vers le haut et c'est ça
vers lequel
confrontés nos nos confrères nos jeunes
confrères qui sont très peu avertis des
difficultés existentielles du métier
quand demain on ne le laissera pas
d'autre solution que d'être des
consommateurs de produits
tu sais comme trait à l'emploi comme
comme la cuisine congelés ou ou sous
vide car il a plus qu'à mettre damon a
plus qu'à mettre ça dans le fourgon
depuis c'est comme ça tu fais ta cuisine
notre destin c'est de faire de la
cuisine de se mettre au boulot est de
faire des ouvrages complexe c'est notre
destin
seule la complexité sauvera et la
planète et les métiers et les savoir
faire qui l'accompagnent c'est à dire le
bien le lien social et le plaisir aussi
de travailler et de vivre ensemble dans
un récit dans une narration pour bâtir
la situer voilà moi aussi je fais un peu
la grande messe et à delhi alors le mot
de la fin
philippe madec en fait le la jeune
génération est une génération si ces
salles qui le fait est qu'elle est
incroyablement bien et concret sur le
territoire français c'est cette
génération là a compris que le quotidien
des architectures ce ne serait pas les
choses exceptionnelles mais une réalité
indispensable a changé et c'est trés
cette réalité la demande un regard
différent sur la ressource et sur la
relation avec les gens tout ce travail
là on n'a pas dit avant on le fait avec
les gens et on ne peut le faire
kg de cirque avec les gens qui souvent
sont contre le béton d'ailleurs il
trouve que c'est sale contient un
chantier en mettons que ces bouées
vous avez conscience et surtout si tu es
l'allusion de rudy ricciotti oui parce
que je me rappelle un jour je
construisais un complexe sportif à lille
est passé notamment vélo à la voyez des
traces de pneus de camions sur la route
et le poney pour un ouvrier parce que
j'ai vraiment une gueule de d'ouvriers
conjoint et elle m'a insultée parce que
les pneus de camions et la boue salissez
la route
alors j ai fait une leçon politique lui
disant qu'il fallait qu'elle comprenne
qu'elle danse addmd de sa vie oisive
elle avait le privilège d'avoir des
ressources financières qui était celle
qu'aucun contribuer les travailleurs et
qu'il fallait qu'elle y pense pour sa
retraite
tiens pas pour seul destin de faire de
la critique des signes de la
transpiration du travail
voilà c'est si notre inspiration du
travail incarnée par là l'empreinte de
la boue des pneus sur la route comme si
c'était aux deux skieront te c'est la
difficile de conscience des autres parce
qu'on n'est pas seuls on est ensemble
je vous remercie tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat philippe madec rudy
ricciotti merci encore merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]